what is up amy so basically
my family is catholic and my long-term
boyfriend
um well technically my fiance is muslim
and
want to get married sweet this is gonna
be an awesome call
all right yes so uh
how can i help so he's your fiance he
asked you to marry him and you said yes
yeah and um i mean i i still haven't
told my family i don't know how to tell
them i've already introduced them to
each other
um how did that go
so in person like they were like
welcoming and charming and this and that
and then like
i visited them a couple days later and
they were like what the hell was that
what do you think you're doing yes
bringing a muslim into this household
like we thought we raised you better
this and that
and to me i was just like totally
blindsided i had no idea that they would
react that way
yeah for sure so um
are you a practicing catholic or are you
more of a catholic
in practice in theory
i mean um you're a theoretical catholic
okay
yeah you know how to go up and down and
do all the stuff in the service but
right okay all right and so is your
fiance is he a practicing muslim are you
gonna have to convert
or is he in like like you are to
catholicism is
he that way to the muslim faith yeah
kind of i mean there's like there's no
pressure but
um i'm pretty sure once we like settle
down and have kids we'll probably raise
the muslim just because they don't
really
connect with catholicism like at all so
okay um but yeah like to me religion is
just like it doesn't matter
that much okay so why are you giving
your parents a vote why do you care
um it's not so much that i'm giving like
my my decision is made i'm gonna marry
him
but um at the time they were like giving
me this ultimatum of like you need to
choose like it's either us or him
um and i was trying to kind of take a
third route like hey i choose me
i choose what makes me happy and they've
like turned it around on me like oh so
you think you can't be happy without us
like so here's the deal they put an
ultimatum on you
but it's not really that they gave the
ultimatum
and so they said him or us
and you chose him and so that's going to
be uncomfortable
and frustrating and gnarly and
heartbreaking and sad and fill in the
blank fill in the blank
but that just isn't is
like how old are you 25
25 yeah you're you're a grown new york
woman
you're one of the most powerful people
on planet earth
i know some really extraordinary new
york women and they are awesome and they
are not to be reckoned with and they are
brilliant
and smart and kind and they know what
they want and
your parents gave you an ultimatum they
said him or
us and you chose him
so when i say it like that you don't
like that how come
um it's just
the whole situation it's my whole life
i've kind of
been like the image of like the perfect
daughter and i hate disappointing my
parents
um and i don't want the ultimatum to end
up like with me actually losing them
um like right now we're kind of at a
place of
like don't ask don't tell like i don't
tell them about him but they don't ask
me about him
yeah but that's that's you that's you
living into
that's you living this mirage that's
this fantasy amy
and in many ways you're becoming
you're you're diminishing your integrity
to be more blunt you're lying to your
family
and yeah in order to keep the peace
you're choosing to keep a
massive part of you the person you're
going to spend the rest of your life
with you're already talking about kids
how you're going to raise those kids um
you're being dishonest with them and so
what i don't want you to do is to take a
moment
that where they showed their cards they
showed who they were they showed their
character
our faith is
more important than you right so you're
going to be on board with our faith or
you're not going to be with
us and you chose
okay cool i call your bluff but i don't
want you to then show your character
by then lying about it
you made your decision you made your
decision
and the reality is you stood by your
values
and when we stand by our values it often
hurts it often costs us something
the sucky part about our current
ecosystem
with social media is that we feel like
we live our values by thumbs downing the
crap out of something right
and we forget that when martin
dr king marched across the bridge he
thought he was going to die
but it was worth it to him right so
that's an extreme example of living your
values but
our values cost us something and in this
case
your parents they showed their values
our way
our faith or we're done with you
my guess is that they're not going to be
done with you
but you've always been the perfect
daughter they think that by leaning on
you in a heavy way
that you'll come back around and here's
the other thing i want to give them some
grace on this
and i know this is going to cost me
people are going to send me mean emails
and letters
um i believe it was pin or teller it was
one
it was one of the the the famous
um magicians in las vegas
um let's just say it was pen but i don't
remember which one
is a is a is a famous uh
atheist that the tall one james tall
yeah
really i've i've the the interviews i've
seen with him the things i've read is
extraordinary he's a brilliant man he's
a kind thinker
but he told a story about he's a devout
atheist too by the way
he told a story about meeting a guy
backstage who was
talking to him about what a great show
he had just seen
what a great magic show the guy was
talking about how impressed he was they
talked
shop about you know technique and things
like that and the guy said hey i've just
got to put it out there i'm a
christian and i'd love for you to come
to church with me tomorrow here in vegas
and um i just want you know i love you
and this devout this atheist don't say
devout but this atheist said
he was so touched and moved because the
guy wasn't trying to move well it wasn't
trying to
um this wasn't a move he didn't hand him
a bunch of tracks he didn't wasn't
trying to beat him up with
he was just saying hey i love you and i
care about your future i care about your
soul
and i want you to know that you're
welcome to join me and what pen
said that stuck with me was when true
believers when true people
who stick by their faith and they
believe it to the core of their being
it's to them like somebody's in a street
and a truck is coming at him
and they push that person out of the way
to save him from that truck
and pin said i don't believe what that
guy was telling me
i don't i don't buy it but i really am
grateful that he
saw me and thought i was going to hit my
truck and he he thought enough of me to
push me out of the way
and so i tell you that story to tell you
this your parents
may be super devout catholics and in
their heart and mind
however right wrong misguided honest
true
whatever word you want to put there they
believe
that if you marry someone who's a muslim
your eternal soul is at stake
the same as your fiance's family might
feel
that if him as a muslim marries a
christian he was to convert to
catholicism that his
actual eternity would be at stake i
would hope they would speak up
i'd hope they'd speak up in love and i'd
hope they'd speak up
directly and firmly and with care but
i'd hope they'd speak up
because they care that much about my
eternal soul
and then i hope they would continue to
love me and that's the decision
all people of faith have to make when
they speak up right
and so think of it this way that your
parents are trying to love you the best
they know how
they're trying to care for their baby
girl who's 25 right you're a grown-up
but in your eyes they're always going to
be seven
and they're always going to love you but
they're trying to love you the best they
can
and they may just be concerned for your
eternal soul
however wrong you think that is however
goofy you think that is
and so in their way of trying to love
you they said it's either him or us you
chose him
and so just know that all you can
control is what you can control you made
your decision
don't let your integrity um sag
when it comes to protecting and trying
to keep the peace there be honest with
them be up front with them and tell them
that you still desire a relationship
with them even though they give that
ultimatum
and then you're gonna have to live by
that decision and that's gonna be hard
amy
is that fair yeah definitely
and so you love this dude absolutely
he treats you right oh yeah okay
so i want you to remember that moment
remember
the values line that you drew somebody
said either or you chose
you chose or and now we're going to all
live with the consequences
every one of us has values
is at some point going to be called on
the carpet myself included
myself included and people of faith who
reach out and say i'm terrified for x y
and z thank them because they're they're
trying to shove you out of a truck they
see coming your way
even if you don't believe that truck's
coming
trust their hearts and their motives
behind that and
oh man and then people of faith speak
your heart speak your mind
and please please default to love
relationships and love
relationships and love